the world rugby values are passion
respect
solidarity integrity uh and discipline
so that's
when the game is over however tough and
sometimes violent it can be during the
the game itself at the end of the game
you
shake hands
legitimately
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders i am so
excited for this episode we're about to
meet pete sickle the ceo of the tel aviv
heat this is a story like no other
it is a different kind of startup story
one
that has to do with sports it has to do
with team with values and it's
fascinating all around to hear how a
sports team is formed the different
challenges that come with it and the
similarities to how close it is to
running a tech startup
thank you pete for joining me in this
amazing amazing conversation and enjoy
everyone
we're in beautiful pacquiao con
what are they
talking about leadership in a different
way a lot of times i have ceos from
software companies venture capital
investors cyber
ceos but here we have the ceo of a
sports team
yeah with the journey that is just as
fascinating as the formation of this
team which is its own startup in its own
right and its own fascinating journey
pete thank you so much for being here
really happy to be here thanks much
we were spending meaningful time
together talking about political science
international relations and global
history and today we're talking about
how you're running tel aviv repeat and
you're competing
globally with the rugby team that you
found it yes
how does that work what happened then
yeah so rugby has gone through rugby the
game has gone through a lot of kind of
transitions it's a it's an old game
but it's only been professional for the
last 27 years since 95.
um
there are kind of the haves and the
have-nots so the top rugby nations in
the world england france new zealand and
so on they compete against one another
but there's something the tier two
nations
have a hard time
getting parody to tier one so world
rugby about a year and a half ago two
years ago said
we need to have an initiative that's
going to help promote tier 2 rugby to
improve their rugby
they went to rugby europe and said let's
start a new professional competition
and rugby europe went out and tapped
there's something called the six nations
england ireland scotland wales france
and italy
let's take the next seven highest-ranked
teams in europe
and start a competition seven's a bad
number for a competition so they open an
eighth wild card slot
they put out then a request for bids any
union in rugby europe's territory israel
is in rugby europe's territory now i
want to pause the story at this moment
because i want to take you back for a
second back to your college days yeah
because rugby you know i i would go and
i would see this in the news and i would
say okay that's awesome they haven't
been an eighth slot but you saw that you
said okay this plays back to something
in your own personal history that ties
back in with an opportunity here yeah
well actually i wasn't involved at this
stage so this is how israel got invited
to put in a bid into this new
competition
so about a year and a half ago the bid
went in and almost exactly a year ago
march of 2021
rugby europe said congratulations you're
in and everyone sort of said when they
said no now first season it had never
happened
when does it start september first game
september so in march
we were a powerpoint
it was a powerpoint presentation to
rugby europe rugby europe was very
impressed saw the opportunity for a
country like israel which is not tier
two in rugby terms it's really kind of
tier four so those other seven teams
were ranked somewhere between 12th in
the world and 25th in the world israel
is ranked 60th in the world so they were
taking a real risk on us but they were
very impressed by the vision that we had
that given the opportunity
to play rugby at a professional level
against other talented teams
you could actually transform a country
from from tier four to tier two and
hopefully above and your personal
interest with rugby so i was introduced
to rugby in high school in los angeles
luckily we had a teacher and a coach he
was american but had lived in new
zealand and he coached us in football
and then sort of said if you guys were
really tough you'd play rugby he did a
little jedi mind trick and we said
what's that and he started a rugby team
he fell in love right away
um
look i had played football and
basketball and baseball in high school
but there was something special about
rugby not only
kind of the freedom and the flow of the
game on the field
but the thing that really got me was the
rugby values and i do want to spend some
time on that because
it's an important
aspect not only for my personal journey
in rugby but i think it's critical to
understanding kind of the tel aviv heat
and before you start that you know we we
met i have believed seven or eight
months ago yeah we were sitting in a
coffee shop and you for about five or
ten minutes you were talking about the
rugby valleys and i had no idea what
rugby was until then yeah i spent the
next three or four hours watching rugby
on youtube
and and really trying to understand what
you were talking about yeah it's pretty
amazing yeah look uh long before i mean
we all know we're in the era
and luckily you know that's valuing
inclusion and respect and equality and
so on rugby has lived those values for
for decades and decades so
you know the the world rugby values are
passion respect
solidarity integrity uh and discipline
so that's
when the game is over however tough and
sometimes violent it can be during the
the game itself at the end of the game
you
shake hands
legitimately genuinely what does that
mean because every team you know is
supposed to shake after everything these
guys are i mean if you really look
carefully if you watch a rugby game at
the end
these are guys who have really been
crashing into each other are giving each
other genuine hugs
and the tradition in rugby is the home
team then actually hosts the visiting
team and so even at the highest highest
professional levels
uh you'll find that the losing team gets
invited into the winning team's locker
room for a beer and these guys are
sitting down next i don't know of that
in any other sport the only thing to me
that comes close to it is uh kind of
boxing martial arts
judo where there's this mutual respect
yes i tried to beat you into submission
but once it's over
thank you for letting me compete against
you amazing and so on a team sport level
i don't know of any other team sport
that really matches this
um so for us
on the tel aviv heat journey once the
the bid was approved uh i got invited to
join the founding team there were three
or four people who put the bid together
um so yeah a year ago i was asked to
come in we didn't have a team name we
didn't have a dollar in the bank we had
no players signed
we had a head coach
he was kevin musicamp he's also was
already the israeli national team coach
he was already in israel he already but
he grew up in south africa he had been
coaching for 20 years
um
he had lots of experience but he started
coaching at a young age
injuries from his playing days made him
shift over to the coaching side uh
earlier probably than he wanted so he's
a young guy with lots of experience
which is pretty unique he had made
aliyah he had emigrated to to israel
a few years prior so
we were very very fortunate that we had
kind of the right person in the right
place at the right time to build the
team but take me back to that day that
you joined yeah the day that you decided
that your
your journey now
is to be a co-founder and ceo of this
new project what is going to turn into a
crazy startup yeah that you're going to
have like any ceo of any tech cert
you're going to have to do everything
just like everybody's doing everything
yeah trying to get this running
what what where's your head at how do
you how do you even structure what your
priorities are yeah and what you're
trying to achieve now yeah the deadline
that you have to face yeah well many
startups yeah well i didn't come in as
ceo there were sort of five or six of us
that were all dedicated to this this new
mission this opportunity we want to do
this let's we're the founding team and
we didn't come in with set roles
who can do what our first
we we had i think until may to sign a
participation agreement with rugby
europe are you guys in and we're in
march and right now it's just a vision
it's a vision it's a powerpoint
presentation it's a powerful vision but
we have no
resources we don't have
sorry to
so the first sort of mission was
we need to make sure that we can be
viable financially
we have to make sure before we sign a
single contract that we will have enough
that we can actually feel the team of a
sufficient quality that we can compete
at a higher level than our israeli
players have ever competed and if you
don't get this by may you may have to
wait we may have to say thanks for the
invitation we'll see you in a year
so
full court press from march to may
let's see how much money we can raise
luckily by may we had raised about a
third of our
target for our seed round and we sort of
said okay if we can do this before we
have a single player sign in a single
game then we're on to something our
vision is not just the five or six of us
others can see the the the opportunity
and the value that we can create in the
future so we signed our participation
agreement
um in june then we were going from the
just raising that seed capital to
we need to really
start defining roles and getting
operational we are going to need to
secure a stadium we are going to need to
start signing contracts and so on how do
you pitch a sports team at that capacity
a new sport that most people here
probably don't know what rugby is yeah
no players yet yeah shared vision yeah
global competition
what is the pitch
yeah well to tell you the truth uh the
pitch was most receptive outside of
israel yeah um and so the the
early investors
um were either very passionate about
rugby and saw this amazing there aren't
that many
one one of the great strengths of rugby
is it's great tradition yeah but here
was an opportunity to build a club from
the ground from scratch and so for
people who've been around rugby and have
their passionate affinities with their
clubs and so on
they were really attracted to wow i've
always thought if i were to build my own
now i have an opportunity to be part of
that so we had the hardcore rugby people
who were drawn to it
we also had people who are hardcore
supporters of israel and said i don't
know anything about rugby but if this is
going to help elevate israel on the
world stage i want to be part of it and
you know how can i help how can i
support and then of course we had
people who were both
who were
you know long time ardent supporters of
israel but also passionate rugby people
and so the the pitch was
this will be the vehicle to elevate
rugby in israel
down the road we see a path
that if we can install a professional
environment here in israel and sustain
it that someday down the line israel
will be in a position to vie for a spot
in the olympics
to qualify for the rugby world cup which
right now seems impossible right now
seems impossible
but now a year later it doesn't seem
impossible at all well and we're in at
that point we're still in april may of
last year exactly incredible yeah you're
in may you secure a third of the funding
yep you signed the contract so you say
we're we're committing to this we're
going to do this yeah
so we signed the contract with rugby
europe they still hadn't announced they
were still in stealth mode
so
look the challenge was to go to we
didn't want just
investors uh uh
we needed investor support but really
for this to be a viable model we need
sponsorship we need television we there
are lots of things that we need
and we couldn't really go to the
sponsors until rugby europe was going to
announce and with their sponsors right
so
they announced in july so it's not
really until july that we could really
engage with sponsors because
rugby europe says you can't really
announce this thing
and we were waiting for rugby europe to
announce their sponsors so we can when
is the season starting september
so
you already have four months of training
from when you're getting to this
contract and now you're taking it down
to two months of training because you
can't really train properly because you
don't have the resources yet we don't
have the reason so most of our contracts
were actually signed in july and august
wow for players
and it's hard to believe now but uh
now and i'll explain it but
we didn't know who would actually sign
up for this thing wow who would take the
chance
to come play rugby and we we didn't have
a name so the tel aviv heat was
i'd like to say it was fully uh market
researched and we have a few of us ah
that sounds good uh you know we found a
logo designer online and here let's go
um
we were very very fortunate as i
mentioned kevin musicamp is the director
of rugby and the head coach
uh
the first hire was his assistant coach
which is a guy dmitry katrikilis who
also had his playing career cut short
because of injury
but demetri and kevin then had an
extensive network of former teammates of
dmitry katrika lee so
when we were trying to get players to
come on
we couldn't wow them with money
we could we couldn't entice them that
this was a get rich enterprise
but the story and it was a legitimate
story was we're gonna give you a great
team to play for
you're gonna love playing for this team
because it is built around players and
what's important to players
and i think this is what separates us uh
from the from the professional rugby
environment
which really treats these players and
i'm hearing this from the players
themselves whether they're playing in
professional leagues in south africa or
england or france
they're treated like assets
and as long as that asset how does that
come to play in the day today how do
what happens in the day-to-day of of the
management of the team
that differentiates between
assets or resources yeah you're just
managing yeah so the the
first and foremost we want to make sure
that
we're meeting their needs
we we know
a year ago that to get them to take the
risk
to come to take the leap of faith to
come play for the tel aviv heat they
have to know that they're coming to an
environment where they are valued and
trusted and listened to and so i've
tried to you know over the course of the
last several months
meet with each player one-on-one and
after they were signed after they're
already played tell me what's what's
been your experience and without fail
it's been some variation on
this is my best experience in rugby this
is the first time
i've been listened to you guys really
care what we think and we need and we
feel so it's
if we didn't do that
we
would have a very very hard time
recruiting
uh and and sustaining talent is this
something so what you're talking about
here you know building a culture right
and that's something that every ceo of
every startup you know is tackling
is this an intentional thing that you
set out yesterday i need every player to
know that they're listened to
so if yes how do how do what's your plan
of attack how do you okay so great so
you signed a player how what do you as a
ceo then strategically do you get him in
three months to come back and say you
know what i really feel like you
listened to me these last three months
well first of all it's to listen to them
so i spent time with them i'm not so
in a way it is though um
uh and you and i know each other from uh
you know i used to be a teacher and so
when i was a young teacher
i needed to prove myself by telling the
students how much i knew
that's not effective teaching
so the the more i got into it and taught
at high school and university
the most effective
uh
the most value i could create in the
classroom was not in what i said it's in
what i could get students to discover
and so taking that attitude and approach
um they needed to know that i was there
not just some guy that's name is on the
contract and i never see you again
so we were on the road for the whole
month of october i was with them i was
with them on the bus
i was folding their laundry in the hotel
in moscow
i was asking them how are things going
i when i met them for the first time
because these guys are coming from
professional environments right they are
coming from clubs that pay them much
more that have a huge organization and
huge fan base and so on and i'd say
thanks for taking the leap of faith and
joining us
we want to give you the best experience
that you possibly can have and if we're
not
come tell me let me know how we can make
this better and then
making sure that when they that did
happen
we weren't defensive we weren't evasive
we weren't we're listening
and we could have honest conversations
and say i would love to give you that
maybe in season two we're building
towards that or whatever so
they needed to know that any promise we
made we delivered on it right um and
when we couldn't deliver on it we didn't
make false promises right so that that
transparency intentionality that we
we're we're all in this together we
can't do it without you and so my
attitude is a ceo i mean i don't know
how cliche it is or whatever but
i see myself as a servant leader so uh
you know
the job of the coach the job of the
player is to compete right let's not
forget it is a competition it's to score
more points than your opposition it's to
win games and so on
but we know from so much research and so
much psychology
the environment that you create for
players is critical to how they perform
on the field so now the coach's job and
the co you know the coaching staff their
job is to create that environment
my job is to make sure that the coaching
environment has the resources right to
actually deliver it so it's it's
starting with the players and moving
backwards and again
um
it's not about what can you do for the
team what can the team do for you sorry
if it's cliche but
that was critical from the very get-go
and so i think for their there
the fact that i was a coach
was very important for me coming it's
not because uh you know
i'm a financial whiz or whatever so when
i'm talking to the coach and he says i
need this for the players and so on
we're speaking the same language exactly
we're in september yeah you as the
leader yeah one of the leaders there you
guys have to align expectations yeah
it's a competition yeah you're bringing
in
com competitors that used to compete in
the professional sphere yeah and you're
approaching your first season yeah this
is gonna be the first time that you're
competing as a team yeah a lot of a lot
at stake yeah sponsors investors
you know this is setting yourself up for
season two yeah how do you strategically
think through okay what do i do now as a
ceo as a leader here yeah to align
expectations yep
yeah look we were we're very very lucky
on on several regards again the people
who came at it from the rugby worlds did
not expect us to cobble look we had
players obviously from israel from south
africa from fiji from uk from namibia
from ireland that moved here that we
would assemble to get so in season one
look there was also covet let's not
forget yeah so when we were planning our
end of august israel was closed wow
so
i can't tell you how many scenarios we
considered for our prese we ended up at
pre-season in south africa
couldn't get the guys we had six players
from fiji couldn't get him into south
africa because they needed visas and
the consulate in fiji was closed
so we meet in georgia
about
five days before our first game this is
the first time well most of the team
meets in south africa but the fijians so
the whole team is together exactly
the whole team is together a few days
before our first game we play against
the georgian black line
it's a team sport it's valuable
absolutely with communication and
collaboration and if there's a little
bit of a misalignment in defense they
score so
really
now we lose
our first game but
georgia is ranked 12th in the world
and a a large percentage of the players
taking the field that day
play on the georgia national team
so we lost but by like 20 points it was
respectable i know that sounds weird a
respectable loss but
immediately
we were getting attention from around
the world on the rug how did you guys do
that where did you
how did you do that
and it all comes back to personal
relationships and trust
so that kevin and dmitry could talk to
players they knew the players
that had some of them had burnt out on
rugby some of them were looking for a
contract and we're no longer cost
effective for whatever
we'll take you come play with us we'll
give you it now we lose
again respectable laws
they're singing in the locker room
and i mean singing
some of you might think of
dirty songs what these are the fijians
singing in four-part harmony
these are guys singing jojo losa the
kind of south african work song there is
joy these guys are singing on the bus
and so we're the the coaches and we're
looking at each other okay we're tapping
into something special if you can walk
off the field losing by 20 points and be
singing with one another it's because
you're seeing each other as family wow
and so
again when we started recruiting we were
wondering who's going to come play with
us
and as soon as someone said i'll sign up
wow we were so excited we
right now we have a waiting list of 200
players at an elite level
because they're hearing from their
friends incredible about telling how do
i get involved how do i get a spot on
the tel aviv heat
we got interest from top professional
clubs in south africa in england in
australia new zealand
how did you guys do that what are you
guys doing you came out of nowhere to to
where you are in four months
and i think
what we've exposed is there's a lot of
conventional thinking i don't want to
say in sports in general but in the
rugby world
there's a lot of conventional thinking
that and i'm getting this from the
conversations from players about their
former professional uh
environments
every hour is scheduled it's top down
it's do this here's the program fit in
or get out because we'll find someone
younger and
cheaper and that just seems like an
antiquated
uh so
look we expect high professional
standards they should be playing
incredibly competitive rugby on the
field
but when we're not
in the gym or on the training session or
watching films
we trust them to figure out what they
need to do
because if we can build that culture of
trust and camaraderie and mutual respect
and
it's not about enforcing it it's about
inspiring them i love it so that that to
me
once we knew that these guys are singing
on the bus win lose or draw we knew we
were into something special
um we
uh
time after time after time conversation
so we had one player i'll just give you
it and
uh gabriella betoya he played for
england u20s he was playing at the
highest level of club rugby in england
um he had gone to france hadn't worked
out not a good fit culture um he was
released
he came to play with us because
demetrian gabs had played with each
other and the harlequins
amazing player
but
no ego and so this is something uh um
uh our marketing officer's daughter just
won the world championship in azerbaijan
over the weekend in world acrobatics
and we were talking about this what is
what does it take to be a world champion
you have to be very very confident
you also have to be very very humble
you have to be confident that you are
going to perform when when the stress
and everything is on the line but you
have to be humble enough to do the work
that you need in order to put yourself
into that position of confidence
so gabs look he he got a contract offer
to go back and play for a professional
club in in scotland it didn't work out
he calls us hey can i come back for a
fraction a fraction of the salary that
these type
so
after our last regular season game um
you know i give him a hug and say thanks
so much for for taking a chance thanks
for so much for coming back and he says
look pete this is the best experience
i've ever had in rugby
so now he's signed he did sign a
contract now to play for the bristol
bears one of the top top teams in the
english premiership
of course we're sad to lose him he's not
going to be playing for us in season two
but we're so proud
that
just having this opportunity of coming
to play for the tel aviv heat now is a
launching pad so
if we can create this culture where 200
guys are on the waiting list how do i
get in if they come and play for the tel
aviv heat and they go on to bigger and
better things i think
it's not a loss it's a feather in our
cap
where do you fit into all of this
where where's pete and yeah in this
thing called tel aviv this new startup
yeah
so um
look season one was uh we didn't have
the luxury of time we didn't have the
luxury of budget to really build out a
front office so it was all hands on deck
we were very fortunate a number of
people volunteered their time
pitched in we were outside of our
comfort zone cross we tried not to cross
lanes but crossing over not people not
doing their core competencies because
we had to make it happen we didn't have
time
the the go to market schedule was
dictated to us yeah we okay so we
couldn't say oh let's spend another
month and and fix the bugs before we
release no
there's there's a calendar the team the
other team's waiting yep
so we went through kovid luckily no one
tested positive we played all six games
although we had to relocate two of our
home games to georgia and we're
really lucky to have them as friends and
hosts
my job then as ceo as i mentioned is to
make sure that the coaches and the
players have what they need to to
perform
um
of course i need to be able to
communicate our story i need to be able
to share
how we're creating value not only in the
short term but in the long term so
originally i think we were very focused
on
building our fan base from the inside
out
and very quickly what we understood was
there are rugby fans around the world
and israel fans around the world
that love supporting us i'm we're
getting stories of my mom has never
watched she's watching the game she's
you know she's cheering she's ordered
the sweatshirt you know i mean we've
tapped into something
that i think in a way professional
sports at some level gets
inauthentic it gets too commercialized
too glossy
too removed
too commoditized and so
i think we have this amazing opportunity
to be kind of everyone's second favorite
team so
keep rooting for your team in argentina
australia england
you have the you have season tickets
you're gonna go to the game and cheer
them but now we have another team
uh an underdog story a family
it's a family it's inclusive so those
rugby values of passion solidarity
respect it's not just on a powerpoint
everything we need to do as an
organization every
every interaction we have internally
with external stakeholders has to be
demonstrating that
because we can't
fall back there is no
there's no hundred years of tradition
there's no
uh you know long list of donors that
every year right there we don't have
that we have to create it so
i think in the end my job
is to make sure that those rugby values
are
inculcated and really embraced
throughout the organization
but also bringing the kind of startup
nation entrepreneurship innovation
into the rugby world and so
again as we talked to other clubs other
unions rugby europe
we exceeded expectations and then some
because in a way
look when we started we're like we don't
have support there is no
cushion there is no
and once we realize to lean into that
there's no one saying that's not how we
do it there's no one saying
here are the lines here's we don't have
to think out of the box there is no box
there is no box so
that opens up all kinds of possibilities
um so
looking ahead for season two my job is
to make sure that we're growing this
worldwide
fan base
um
we are starting to attract the look we
were very lucky our initial sponsors uh
scitec and myheritage
based here
uh you know saw the value understood
that this was an opportunity uh to get
in at the beginning but now we're
starting to attract global brands so
we're just about to announce i guess now
uh royal caribbean is coming on royal
caribbean cruise lines
uh we are about to go to south africa
for a 10-day tour on the invitation of
the blue bulls one of the best teams in
the world wow um
so yeah we're we're really excited for
season two
yeah i think our our challenge then is
we can now i as far as my job of course
it's to find
those partners whether they're investors
or sponsors who are going to grow with
us on this on this worldwide level but
it's to make sure as an organization we
do not lose that
ability to provide a safe trusting
environment where it's about the players
it's about the employees
it's about sharing and making sure that
they're having a valuable experience
um and and again going back to the
listening what do you need and how can
we how can we give it to you the
intrinsic motivation here i mean that's
the theme of this whole conversation i
mean everybody's talking about how team
and culture is everything
it's it's so rare to find and i think
what you're talking about here it's
truly embodies the spirit of
authentic intrinsic motivation building
a culture of mutual respect mutual
responsibility not a top down here is a
schedule fit in or fit out this is the
team this is our shared vision yeah
right now we're five five people around
the table okay now we actually are
sending the contract okay now we're
actually a team and maybe we come
together just five days before the game
and maybe we lose the game in a
respectable way but we're still going to
sing together and so because we're doing
it authentically we're going to sing the
whole ride back on the bus and we're
getting prepared for season two and tell
view heat is a family yeah before it's a
sports team absolutely i think that's
just for me uh you know as a learner
as a listener here that that's inspiring
and uh pete thank you for years of
inspiration beyond just this
conversation uh best of luck with season
two it's really it's phenomenal i can't
believe you know hearing the story that
i didn't know most of it now
from hearing about it seven months ago
just incredible and i'm gonna take a lot
of lessons to my own company one day
from what you're embodying here and the
spirit that you're bringing as the ceo
and and as one of the leaders of this
great family so thank you very very much
thanks michael appreciate it
[Music]
you